cool
so welcome everyone to dc thursday i'm
pete soderling
i'm the founder of data council and the
data community fund
and as you know i'm your guide through
the
crazy evolving wild west of the data
ecosystem
and we're here today with another
awesome guest
he's the founder of a startup which is
one of our favorite personas on the
program
and so i want to welcome tejas manohar
to the program
tejas has been well first of all he's
the co-founder
of a new company called high touch and
formerly
he was a tech lead and engineering
manager at segment
and before that a visiting scholar at uc
berkeley
so tejas welcome pete
it's great to be on the show thanks for
having me yeah thanks for being here
i want to also remind the audience that
if they have any questions for tejas
during our conversation that they can
jump into the youtube chat
and uh we'll work them into the
conversation to the best of our ability
so tejas i want to start with your
background because
you have a sort of a non-traditional
background which always jumps out at me
maybe because i i self-identify but i'm
i'm curious to hear about
um sort of the the early days and and
how you got into tech can you tell us
more about that
yeah so i actually got into programming
um just back in like school i said i was
programming first to
to actually make like games and websites
and cool things like that that i used
every day and i wanted to learn how to
do myself um and it wasn't it wasn't
anything really related to data
engineering at the time for sure it was
more like
hobbyist programming uh when i got into
high school i actually
got an internship at a very small local
startup that i read about in a newspaper
it was like three four people
they had gone through the 500 startups
program at uh
in sf and come back to nashville where i
grew up and
where i'm visiting back right now and
then when i actually
interned there this was back in i think
2014
they were using a product called they
were using a product called segment
basically to manage their analytics
stack and they were an early customer of
this service
um i think segment was maybe a year old
at max right now i was really just
getting
its stride as a company team of less
than 10 or
maybe even five people at the time and
we were one of the early users
and basically a segment to push our
analytics metrics into a few different
services google analytics mixpanel
and i don't remember what the other one
was but we kind of pushed them all into
these services via one universal client
on the front end
and um it was it was pretty incredible
to see
how great the product was and i started
following the company after that for the
next couple years and eventually
i saw how fast this company was growing
and what a large pain point it solved
that i decided to just
reach out and try to join myself roughly
two years later when the
team was about 30 people and maybe eight
engineers um
so that that's really how i broke into
tech i worked worked a couple small jobs
in between
a different startup instrumented segment
over and over and just realized that
that was the company i wanted to work at
instead and that the product vision
behind
um kind of centralizing customer data
was much more exciting
than i than the consumer apps i was
working on
got it well i want to dig into your
experience that segment
um but but before we do that when did
the
visiting scholar at uc berkeley come
along um and how did that happen
yeah so since i actually joined segment
directly after after high school i kind
of deferred my college admission
a few times the company was growing and
i i wanted to know
um whether i should should actually go
to college
decided not to i want to fast forward
the story here uh but
one of the things i wanted to do when
making that decision across is
see what it's like to work in a research
lab because that's something that always
fascinated me
in concepts i just something i just
didn't know about
and i thought you know it'd be cool to
try my hand at this and see if that's
something i'm interested in
more than the startup thing just like
how working at segment wasn't
more interesting than working on
consumer stuff for me so
i reached out to some labs that had
interesting projects and ended up
joining one of them as like a visiting
researcher um
and i it was it was a pretty great
experience
actually the the the project i worked on
the lab
it wasn't as exciting as segment was to
me and the great trajectory of the
company
but they did spin out into a separate
startup from the lab which is pretty
exciting
actually a number of companies have spun
up and the startups from
these couple labs in berkeley like data
bricks facility like a lot of companies
just run out
and now it all comes around full circle
because
one of the co-founders of that startup
actually works at high touch now since
that startup didn't really
hit its stride which is super exciting
he's basically one of our lead back in
engineers today
interesting and how did you make the
connections with that lab at berkeley in
the first place i'm curious
yeah so i think one thing i've gotten
really good at over the years
in terms of just getting opportunities
that i i probably am not qualified for
whether it's selling our product when we
were in the early days or
um just getting a job at segment for
example or getting internships at
compass hub spawn high school just
getting really good at cold emailing i
think i think my biggest talent is
probably just like
being an sdr maybe rather than even an
engineer honestly
i think i i ended up emailing a ton of
professors like sending really
personalized messages you know
just like i guess sending something
detailed enough to try to get in i think
i think what's interesting about
emailing people who
are actually a pretty well standing like
you know have wikipedia pages and
are on the board of data bricks and
stuff like that is i don't think they
actually get that many emails from
people in industry
asking if they want to volunteer at
their lab at berkeley uh so i think when
people do get an email that's exciting
enough
um in that regard and isn't just
templated like they actually respond
pretty well
well to it and i think that's something
i've just like learned over the years
that's that's how i got all my jobs
all my internships back in back in
school uh a lot of our early customers
to be honest and
just like kind of hustling network and
cold
outreach unlike then yeah i like that
being the sdr for yourself um i think
that's something that
that most many engineers don't think of
and
um i can i i can definitely understand
and identify with that because that was
a
that sort of process in motion was super
helpful to me in my early career as well
yeah
the impact that cold emails and just
outreach like that has had on
on my you know career trajectory or
personal trajectory even has just been
massive like
i met so many people via via cold
outreach and
um it's not the main way we acquire
customers as a business today
we do have a small sdr function it's not
the main way we require customers today
but
it is it has been pretty impactful for
for scoring some
some early customers contacts in the
industry learning from other companies
it turns out that with a well-written
email a lot of people are willing to
talk to you just given how much spam
people get on a day-to-day basis
yeah that's a great insight so so
cool so you ended up at segment um you
were one of the earlier
uh engineers there you said the company
was about 30
30 people or 30 engineers did you say at
the time
yeah it was about about 30 to 40 people
and i think i was around
the eighth eighth to tenth engineer at
the company oh i see
it was it was an awesome environment we
had so much scope of work for the team
that we had honestly uh
is is really incredible and we were all
working out of a pretty small office in
in sf which was
a lot of fun i remember when i
interviewed at the company i was like
wow there's like
30 people in here this office is it's
massive
and then two years later it wasn't
really the case
we had grown like 150 in that office and
it was it was totally crammed and
no longer massive but yeah it was an
exciting journey at the company
um when i joined i think just with a
team of like eight engineers we had
at least three products going on and
a hundred to two hundred integrations
just
absolute craziness and it's amazing
resources yeah for sure um that the
company was a rocket ship and i'm
curious to know like what was the state
of the data platform
um at the time what that you joined
yeah yeah so i can't remember the exact
stats about how much
data we were processing but we
definitely had some numbers and
billions or tens of millions of being
like super happy about processing this
this amount of data per month i think it
was
impressive for our time and scale but
that number grew
extremely rapidly since then um and
the state of the data platform uh
originally segment was written in node
i switched some of the infrastructure
over to go since um
and that was plus and minus one year
that the transition was incremental kind
of plus and minus one year from from the
time i joined a lot of the core
infrastructure was moved over
um and we were using nsq throughout so
kind of each part of segment would be uh
connected through
basically a series of queues so the
front door api would write all analytics
events
that are coming into the platform into
one queue that we forward that to
another series of queues for different
destinations and archiving services
and the data warehouse pipeline should
be kind of like queue after queue and a
series of microservices
in retrospect it was a pretty complex
infrastructure to manage especially for
a team of eight to ten people and
um i would say it ended up getting more
complicated over time
and definitely there are definitely a
number of learnings there i
but it did work and and and was able to
run a pretty large scale
for the team we had mm-hmm and
so and what products you mentioned that
you had a few different products
um what products were you involved in uh
when you tried
so when i joined um this is actually an
interesting story so when i when i
joined
the first project that i worked on at
segment was building a competitor to
what
five train is today so essentially at
segment
uh for anyone who doesn't know we had
our core product which
allowed companies to collect events like
collect information about their users
and what events they're doing
in their applications on web mobile
backend
store checkout etc and
when you send these events a segment
what it would do is they would forward
them to a variety of different services
initially just analytics platforms later
marketing platform support platforms etc
that would benefit from having access to
that customer data
without you having to integrate each and
every one and that was really exciting
to me because it was something i used
in the past company um but uh but as
as kind of segment expanded it got more
and more customers and the data space
started evolving our customers started
asking us to do um
more and more things around customer
data and just kind of become an
all-in-one bundled solution while there
were no
de facto best of breed players in the
space of the time
so one of the things that customers
asked for is not just sending data to
analytics and marketing services but
also
data warehouses when redshift started to
take off
um so segment was one of the the first
companies to integrate with redshifts in
a really easy self-service capacity they
called it segment redshift at the time
now it's called warehouse's product um
but it allows you to send all the data
using this segment just to read shift in
like
one click don't have to do any sort of
coding and that was that was just
crazy at the time um one thing that we
that customers started asking us when we
had more and more
uh companies using redshift is how do i
get the rest of the data for my company
in redshift how do i get my data from
salesforce from zendesk from
mailchimp marketo from all these tools
into my redshift database
um not just my analytics events from the
website that i'm collecting
and at the time we looked at the market
and we basically saw okay
there are a number of startups working
on this as redshift in particular starts
to explode this was before snowflake and
bigquery etcetera had really hit this
right
in terms of mid-market um and there was
five trans there was illuma
stitch data i think they had a little
back story with rj metrics
it's a number x plenty just a number of
companies doing this exact thing
um on the redshift wave but we looked at
and we're like they all look
basically the same they're all building
connectors super fast and
it feels like the space is gonna strive
towards commoditization
we had segment of way more customers
than all of them it's combined probably
so let's let's build a a platform to
ingest data from various data sources
into the warehouse ourselves and it
turned out that we did do that
that was my first project at segment
basically building competitor five trans
and those services when there was no de
facto winner and we did get pretty high
adoption within our own customer base
but
as a startup it's just hard to do
multiple things at once
and i think that's the lesson we learned
pretty well at segment i wouldn't say it
was a bad decision in retrospect
it helped people see a broader vision of
segment you know justify paying segment
more et cetera
and tons of companies using segments
still use the cloud sources product
today
um but we never really gave it the same
investment and like founder level
commitment and incentives and stuff like
that
that say a company like five tran or
independent company executing on this
problem did
and in retrospect those companies grew
way way faster
um and just just really focused on on
being a best of breed solution for that
um rather than doing everything at once
and i think that's an interesting
interesting learning respect it's
definitely
still a positive thing for segments they
did this but it's not the outcome that
we expected for in the industry we
expected this to be commoditized it
turns out
few companies really pushed through
built those hundred plus connectors
maintained them really well
did the community decide really well i
just just hammered through it for like
what
eight eight years at this point got it
um but at the same time that sort of
expanded your vision
um you know towards the data warehouse
and so i think some some good things
happened out of that um you know talk to
me about some of the other insights that
you developed over that time
totally so at my time at segment um
not just did i that i work on the cloud
sources product but afterwards i worked
on the core warehouse pipelines and
eventually i started working on this
product called
presonus which which is what segment is
trying to shape their whole vision
to be today and i'm not an insider but
at this point
probably has bulk of their revenue from
on the enterprise side too
um so personas basically said this one
thing which was
companies want a central database of
customer information that marketing can
have like a nice ui to go in
and activate this data so they want
marketing to be able to go in
to this user database inside a segment
and take subsets of users
transform them build new traits on them
uh take make cohorts of them and sync
those over to different downstream tools
and add platforms email platforms
etc so this was the goal of the
persona's
product now it's an entire industry and
ecosystem around customer data platforms
but when working on this i realized a
couple key things
um and key insights that led me to
actually found high touch
so one thing i realized is that our goal
with personas was really to centralize
all customer data all data about a
customer
into one platform and segment be the
source of truth
and give marketers an interface to
activate it the first thing i realized
was that
most companies even those that use
segment
didn't have all their data represented
in segment um
so companies would instrument you know
analytics events and things like that
when you get to when you start and and
that solved the real problem forwarding
those to a variety of services but when
you talk to companies they were still
workflows that segment customers where
you know csvs were being passed around
between teams or one-off scripts were
being written here and there
at segment we always saw this segment of
the other world where some would file a
sport ticket asking how do you do it
this way or how do you do it that way
and how do you segment to do this
but they never really told us what they
were not using segment for
at least as an engineer i didn't have to
review into that which is a really
interesting
phenomenon you get into when you when
you have a company that is super useful
but you don't realize you're not solving
the full problem because they're
actually using
a bunch of other services for other
things and they just see the problem in
that way
um so that was really interesting i
realized that basically companies didn't
have all the data they needed in a
segment and then two what i realized was
a lot of companies had that data in data
warehouses
um so that basically led us to the idea
of
creating a cdp directly on top of the
data warehouse
and through a variety of different
learnings we ended up at what high
pitches today
which is basically a platform for
companies to operationalize the data and
their data warehouses
so the idea is that companies have tons
of data in their warehouse
it's getting easier than ever to collect
it into there via tools like five tran
and stitch and it's getting easier than
ever to model that data
into the source of truth for for your
your
customer information using tools like
dbt but what's lacking
is really a way for for the teams around
the company to use that data and
operationalize that did on an everyday
basis so
i can i can make a look or dashboard or
a mode report
of you know how many leads per day have
this certain lead score and stuff like
that but if i want to present that
information like which leads to focus on
to the sales team
i really need to get that information
into salesforce scale or just a huge
enablement
and just human process challenge
likewise if i want to run ad campaigns
off that data i need to push it to an ad
platformer
email campaigns an email platform
financial reporting
a financial reporting platform like
netsuite or salesforce or whatever it is
so that's what we do at high touch we
basically say the source of shoot for
customer data is no longer
going to be a proprietary sas instead
it's going to be your own data warehouse
which you have full control of the data
models in
and high touch will help you take those
data models and synchronize them
with the systems of action around your
company whether that's like a
sales crm like salesforce marketing crm
like braze or iterable or
sendgrid or you know an ad platform or
slack notifications or whatever it is
and and this is the notion that you call
reverse etl
if i'm not mistaken totally there's
definitely a few terms floating around
the space for it
reverse etl is um basically our
engineering term for it or a data term
for it
and it's the reason why we choose
honestly it's not because it's a flashy
term it's it's because it's so intuitive
um i think that the term almost chose us
in in various customer calls
customers would just say early customers
in fact still today would say
oh is this basically the reverse of an
etl process or is this the reverse of
five training
um it's naturally fit to say yeah this
is reverse etl etl takes data and puts
it into the warehouse
uh reverse etl takes that data and from
the warehouse and moves it into the back
into the systems of records
which you typically see as data sources
um
so yeah that's that's the that's the
idea behind it as we start selling high
touch to more and more
business users and business leaders and
things like that
we have to pick other terms that are you
know more approachable by let's say a
marketing leader or a sales leader
but as we're selling it to data teams
which is our focus today
um reverse ctl is just such an intuitive
uh intuitive term and really just fits
nicely into
a modern data stack yeah i get it that
makes perfect sense
well before we talk more about the
hi-touch product um
i just kind of wanted to dig in with you
a little bit on on what it's like to
start a company
as an engineer because i know there's
lots of engineers in our audience
that watch the show and um that come to
our events and conferences
and um you know i meet them often and
i'm having started
four companies myself as an engineer i
try to help them however i can
but um it's always great to hear from
other folks in the community
like what what were the challenges um
starting a company as an engineer what
was scary like
did you ever sort of think about not
doing it i'm just interesting
sort of interested in the psychology
around you making the decision to to
leave a good job at segment
um and ultimately start your own thing
like what what what did you have to get
through and work through
to get there yeah it's a great question
so
i might be in a different case but i
think i kind of always wanted to
start a company i seeing entrepreneurs
on tv
seeing how widespread technology could
get and just terms of adoption
and i always just had kind of an
ambition to start a company
this probably dates back to like
honestly middle school
at this point i knew i wanted to do
other things i knew i there was a lot of
things i wanted to do in life
even being a doctor was probably one of
them at the time but starting a company
and just starting
like a large business that lots of
people interact with
um and created something from ground up
was just always exciting
what it was in i didn't know the time
but that was always an exciting idea
making the jump was still extremely
difficult i've i'd had a lot of
different side projects growing up and
um some did okay some a lot didn't a lot
didn't even get off the ground so making
the jump to actually
leave my full-time job was difficult
until it basically got to the point
where honestly
my full-time job wasn't that exciting in
complete transparency
i i think the first couple years and a
few years at segment
i have no regrets about my time at
segment it was great learning experience
i thought you wouldn't be around if not
for staying inside
for so long to be completely honest um
but after working at the company for a
few years it just reached a scale which
wasn't as exciting
i mean they were like you know 400 500
600 people at the company
it's pretty clear that uh we would have
an exit at some point
when he was nearing like a 100 million
which is
over now it's much more than that but at
the time it was over
much over 10x i when i joined and it was
just
i'd already seen the growth trajectory
that i wanted
at the company i never and i no longer
felt that being at the company was the
most unique opportunity for me me
career-wise
so i had a couple options i could either
start something
a couple ideas floating around or join
one of my friends that was working on
something
and this is where the story gets
interesting so initially when i left
segment i
actually i lived with a handful of
people
still do ah and two of them were
starting their own companies at the time
um they'd already been working on them
on the side for a while one was
uh my co-worker from segment josh i
became friends with that segment and
actually originally hired onto the
presonus team where we worked on this
product together
uh and he was starting a company in the
iot space and then the the other one was
kashish
who was actually working on a travel
company initially
um and worked on it for a while before
before i joined and
just just just got into ysc actually and
decided to
at the time i didn't know what i wanted
to do but i think i didn't want to do
developer tools again or something like
that it's excited to work for
work with work with kashish for some
work with kashish on
on the travel company and a year later
we
ran into this thing called cobin the
travel company was severely affected by
that and we started kind of
thinking about other ideas we've been
noodling on high ditch being one of them
at the same time josh who who was living
with us and
working the same room with us the whole
year was
was facing some product market fit
problems with his company and decided
the pivot has fallen we decided to just
all team up
so it was a pretty it's a pretty
interesting story in retrospect
basically um basically i ended up
working with
both of the people that i was
considering working with at the time and
on a new idea which i was kind of
considering at the time
instead of the ideas that they were
working on all due to oh really i'll do
the covet and in retrospect
and i i honestly think um most important
thing when
when when joining a company the thing
that really hit it for me was
uh it was not the idea or anything like
that it was just um
the people i i would get to work with so
just just having a good
a good founding team a good uh group of
co-founders
um that was the biggest thing for me
that that helped me get over the edge of
of making the jump uh as an engineer i
think doing it alone it would have been
difficult in retrospect but
um with a good group of co-founders it's
just much easier to justify it it's just
way more fun and weightless yeah yeah so
it's so true is finding the right
co-founders
um is that maybe half maybe more more of
the battle
sometimes it seems well that's a great
story i'm really glad that
that you guys were able to to band
together and come on a covid um with
such a cool product
um and you know some of that is luck and
being in the right place at the right
time and i'm sure some of that is
just your own individual passions and
experience at certain things before that
maybe hadn't worked out so well which is
um often you know the
the case the back story with a lot of
companies that are successful but
um weren't in a previous incarnation or
a previous startup
that the founder had launched so um so
yeah that's that's very real world
experience and
i appreciate you sharing that um so
sort of coming back to high touch um
i wanted to so so you've pioneered this
new category of reverse etl
it's not just how the data gets into the
warehouse but you're starting to talk
about how the data gets out of the
warehouse
which essentially extends the etl
pipeline
um sort of to the right side of the data
warehouse
who like when you're um because this is
somewhat of a new concept
um and you're trying to sell it and
explain it um to customers
like who do you typically find your
customers are like who whose eyes
lights light up when you talk about this
this technology um who has this need and
um sort of how have you identified what
the customer profile is
yeah totally so i think this is a really
interesting one for
for our company in particular um because
pretty much every company struggles with
the problem of data integration
that that makes it easy in some ways but
also
really hard in other ways to decipher
who your ideal customer should be
one would intuitively think oh every
company has customer data problems
every company should be a customer of
high touch and i think that is the case
in the long term
um in the short term if we just took
that approach
uh and some of this is is deliberate
again
a lot of this is actually lock and just
right place right time such sort of
thing
but if we just took this widespread
approach to finding custom customers
high touch wouldn't be at the state that
that it is today
um what was really really impactful for
us was finding the right
initial customers that would have a high
hit rate of sorts
the right communities and circles where
where our ideal early adopters live
um to really take off and get a ton of
organic growth early on in our company's
life cycle which has been
tremendous for us from a business
perspective otherwise we probably have
to do the sdr
i mentioned earlier and just be emailing
people these are software
but essentially what we found was this
group of users
um in the dbt community so for anyone
who doesn't know dbt
probably everyone knows at this point
the tvt is basically
an open source tool with also a sas
offering
that allows you to easily model data in
your warehouse
using just sql so before to do data
modeling in your warehouse and transform
and transform raw tables into normalized
ones and kind of
build a whole dag of these
transformations you would have to be a
data engineer and use tools like
python and airflow and all these sort of
platforms to
engineering platforms to to do data
modeling dbt realized that
the hard part about data modeling is the
modeling itself sql and super expressive
language to do this
and let's make a framework that's dead
simple so that an
analyst can basically become a data
engineer anyone who knows equal can
operate like a data engineer and
that really reduced the uh
the barrier entry for data modeling at
at companies that previously didn't have
the capacity to hire a big data
engineering team or do all this sort of
work so that the sequel that you could
write to get answers at a company could
be much more accessible because you're
working on a
cleaned up well-modeled data set so what
we found was that
users who had adopted dbt and started
modeling data left and right in the
company
had started creating a new source of
truth for data in their warehouse
so the problem of getting data into into
tools like salesforce etc is a global
problem
but in terms of what how we solve it by
moving data out of the warehouse we
really had to look for customers that
were
ready to use our solution on the get-go
when they heard about it and didn't need
a lot of convincing
and those were users of dbt and tools
like dbt that basically help you model
data in the warehouse super easily
because when you're building these new
data models in the warehouse like
what's the user's arr trajectory what's
the user's ltv what's their churn risk
what's their
actual name what are all all their
profiles from all these different tables
combined
you're building those source of truth in
the warehouse via dvt you don't have
that source of truth anywhere else
the warehouse itself kind of becomes a
silo almost in that regard
within an organization and can only be
approached by people who know sql or bi
tools or anything like that
and by having the source of truth the
unique
source of truth in your data warehouse
uh it basically
creates the need for high-tech as a
solution which is a really easy way to
bring that source of truth from the
warehouse since the research
versus companies you just have data raw
data from a variety of things in the
warehouse
they might even prefer a point-to-point
approach where they're connecting sales
first directly to your netsuite or using
some totally non-warehouse-based
architecture for this
like a mulesoft or something like that
so i think for us
in the long term we believe that high
touch is a solution that's going to
prevail and we have to
really make our product more and more
accessible to companies help them
through that data maturity curve etc
um but in the short term what really
helped us get our stride as a company
was
finding that ideal customer profile that
just got it instantly
you could post about how excited they
are about this product and just
tons of people like them would see it
and for us that was the dvd user
community
yeah that makes perfect sense and it
reminds me of this insight that someone
shared with me once regarding
um how to question your early users
about
in sort of a structured way so that you
get a clear picture
of not just how they're using your
product because
that's pretty obvious to you based on
product analytics
the the more interesting and often more
important questions
for for an early user were what were you
doing immediately before
you reached for high touch like what was
the thing that you were doing
um for instance with your data
transforming with dbt in your warehouse
trying to solve some particular kind of
problem
and then all of a sudden you know
importing that data back into a
a customer or a line of business tool
using a tool like high touch um becomes
totally obvious but it's a step before
that can sometimes unlock insights into
what other
a large group of customers um you know
at scale would want to do and what
they're doing before they immediately
sort of reach
it for your spiritual um so i've always
found that a helpful insight
completely and i think i think at first
we were like you know this black
community doesn't have that many users
like how many companies would have this
problem like are we slicing the the
world
of our potential customers too much and
really in reality you need to find
something where you can get
a really high hit rate of your customers
if you're reaching out to a thousand
companies and
just a few of them need your product
that's just not a strategy that's just
gonna work for
for an early stage startup at least
selling the contract sizes that we are
you know where it's like accessible and
self-service and not some
massive enterprise thing where we're
selling 10 million dollar contract to
walmart
but in our in our in our stage you
really need to find that high hit rate
you need to find where your users that
just immediately get it live
um obviously there's some messaging
problems and stuff like that there but
once you find that that's what really
unlocked um
a really big trajectory for our company
and since then we've been lucky in a lot
of regards but
uh the dvd slack user group has grown
like crazy
um the adoption of the software has just
grown massively outside of the community
as well
basically it's come to the point where i
think over half of our prospects are
either using dbt
trying dbt or like about to try dbt
which is pretty incredible
we do have tons of companies that don't
use dbt alternatives these in-house
solutions etc now and it's not a
prerequisite to using our product
in any regards um but it did allow us to
get our first 10 customers for tons of
feedback and
um just just a level of virality and
word of mouth
and aside from from using dbt to
transform data
in the data warehouse um what do you
think customers were doing
before high touch they were essentially
sort of crafting
flat files and importing flat files back
into
salesforce or like how is the world like
i'm sure there was a subset of customers
or people that were sort of trying to do
what high touch offers in terms of
importing stuff back like
what do you think those systems look
like and what were some of the pains of
the world
um you know in in that batch
totally yeah it basically narrows down
to csvs and scripts
you're just comfort doing nothing csv's
and scripts so there's tons of companies
that do nothing they don't have customer
data good customer data their own
systems
their sales teams can't see what's going
on in the product
different marketing teams can't
personalize the email communications
that they send you
and that's why honestly a lot of sales
suck it's like did
this guy even check what i'm doing the
product i've already been using i'm
already happy i just want to pay
and that's why a lot of marketing sucks
as well just do you know
don't know who you are as a user so
doing nothing is the biggest category
i think for companies that are doing
well and growing quickly um
csvs and scripts are what we see
happening
i and csvs meaning exporting data from
bi tools and stuff like that and
importing it or
doing some excel magic before you import
it and just doing that on a manual basis
which obviously has tons of limitations
in terms of how quickly you can get that
data down tools how reliable
it is um what happens when that person
who does that who leaves
a lot of different scenarios there and
then when companies hit all those
problems
the other solution was oftentimes
scripts i think can be
companies who are already thinking about
the problem companies were already
thinking about the problem
uh in the same way we are um
by the time we launched high touch which
is pretty awesome at first we were like
is that worried some like companies are
able to create scripts to do this and
some of the companies be like oh my
scripts are fine when we talk to them
six months later a lot of those
companies became customers of high touch
because
they needed a new integration a new use
case an engineer left
it hit an error a variety of things and
it turns out people just want to pay a
sas
solution to not have to think about this
at all um so i think
if you see workflows that are happening
in complex
manual excel type things csv uploads or
you see
companies writing script to solve
problems that means it's a pretty big
problem with the company
and ignore the people who seem to have
it under control and just focus on the
ones that
that don't because the chances are
there's plenty of companies that don't
and the ones that do have it under
control
won't have it under control in in due
time
so yeah those are what we see ourselves
replacing pretty often
at companies that are thinking about the
problem the same way as us
for example like one of our customers at
lucidchart um
told us like a marketing ops person from
lucidchart actually told us that after
the data team
implemented hi-touch she no longer has
to
wake up every saturday and sunday
morning to put a csv
into marketo and have problems which is
actually incredible that
they have to do that to power automation
prior to this um
and many of our customers are like oh i
don't even have to think about scripts
anymore so
a lot of similarities there i would say
one other thing we're seeing is
there are classes of companies who
weren't thinking about the problem
uh the way we were initially but now due
to high touch and due to our marketing
and stuff like that
they're starting to think about the
problem differently so now we're not
just collecting
you know dbt community users that we're
building script or was just searching
for the solution but we're also getting
users who come from
seeing spaces like ipass where you point
salesforce apis and netsuite apis and
marketo apis and do integration and kind
of like a visual ui that's basically
programming
becomes a giant ruth goldberg machine of
data integration
uh it's like basically an enterprise
version of zapier we're getting a lot of
customers from these sort of services
we're also getting a lot of customers
who were previously trying to assemble a
source of truth in a
cdp and saying huh the data warehouse is
actually where all my data lives let's
build a cdp right on top
yep got it um and what sort of
size of team would you say is reaches
for a solution like high touch is there
is there a particular profile or size of
data team
that ends up like looking for a tool
like this or do you have you know very
small companies or
um you know very very small like what's
the smallest team you have i'm curious
who's
using the solution yeah
we do you have the company here okay so
we our kind of sweet spot is
companies that have a data warehouse um
companies that have good data in the
warehouse
so they have data from five trend things
like that and then if they use dpc it's
like
you need high touch for sure they don't
use dbt inside they still
might need height to a lot of our early
customers didn't use cpt
um still a lot of them so a lot of them
do uh
do not yet and they're still into
adopted or something of that nature um
but having a data warehouse and having
good data in it is actually generally a
prerequisite we're seeing that happening
early and earlier in companies which is
super exciting for our business
um i think when we close retool as a
customer i feel like they were just you
know
20 25 people kind of no code tool to
build internal dashboards which is
pretty early stage for having a data
warehouse and all all these kinds of
shenanigans
um close similar companies like zeppelin
mixmax just just really like startups i
do do use our product pretty
successfully now which is
exciting from perspective of just day
random companies are signing up and just
getting value out of the product without
talking to like anyone in that nature
um but luckily that and what we knew
from the beginning is this thing scales
up all the way to the enterprise where
basically
the data warehouse is the only solution
to this problem because your data is
just so complex that
you can't build a source of truth in
another system um
and there's just so much history behind
it behind it so now we're working with
you know publicly traded companies
like auto trader uh breakout companies
like unicorn companies you know like
lucidchart and uh plaid and
matamos and a variety of those companies
as well um
and it's it's a pretty wide range i
think we even do have some companies
less than 10 people who just have
specific needs that made them create a
data warehouse just plug high-touch
right up to a production database and
start creating
slack feeds and crm notifications and uh
automating different things around their
company off their source of truth
customer data
got it um and are there any particular
use cases that
that high touch isn't suited for um in
this category like how do you think
about
what the tool isn't good at yeah it's a
great question
so one thing that's a limitation of high
touch right now and i think this is
being overcome slowly and slowly luckily
it's what we're seeing from the customer
side
is basically the uh the ingestion
latency and just the whole latency of a
data warehouse-based pipeline
data warehouses are getting faster if
batch operations are getting a lot
faster too
but the by default like at most
companies we can assume that these
operations are happening on
an hourly basis or everyday kind of
basis or something like that
which limits high such from being used
for shared use cases when logged up to a
data warehouse
a majority of use cases from what we're
finding can be solved in a
in a batch pipeline um and companies are
all making their data warehouses faster
but there are certain specialized use
cases
that truly need to happen in real time
like for example if i check out an item
in a store at starbucks and i want to
send a notification immediately after
that happens with my receipt
i just really can't do that via the data
warehouse the main stream data whereas
today
um what's interesting here as a trend is
like
i think i just as a tangent trend here
is that i think
a lot of companies have prioritized
easier and more accessible and more
reliable data infrastructure over
quote-unquote more powerful or better
infrastructure so we looked 10 years ago
all the hype was real-time systems uh
things like apache flink were coming out
and
spark streaming and like all these view
new products to do things in real time
and then batch infrastructure actually
just got
way better and way easier to use uh and
way easier to
adopt more reliable and more scalable
cloud services like snowflake came out
and
batch infrastructure got so good that
people forgo their requirement that they
had in real time earlier
because it just created so many
different headaches for
a company from an operational
perspective that led to
ineffectiveness in doing things
throughout the organization
at scale and in that case people really
sacrifice some power for
for reliability ease of use and
productiveness which i think is a really
interesting trend
now we're seeing now that that
global uh you know default way to store
all your customer data and quarry it
like snowflake and other cloud data
warehouses
is main our mainstream we're seeing
those companies start to
invest more in making streaming
capabilities and real-time capabilities
in the warehouse itself so we know
snowflake has a team on this google has
a team on this
and they publicly write about this and
there's also a variety of startups
tackling this problem from a different
angle like for example materialize
we're really excited about all the
competition in the space and and and how
it's going to drive forward the
warehouses in general
but right now we see that as a as one of
the
the limitations of um kind of the
underlying platform
that we sit on top of uh which which
affects some of the use cases for our
software
the other thing is yeah if you don't
have a data warehouse hike which is
generally not a good fit
there are great use cases for
point-to-point services
we use zapier at high touch we connect
our calendly to our slack via zapier
i don't need my currently data inside of
inside of my data warehouse to send a
slack notification
to to me every time i'm meeting this
book i just don't really need that
doesn't provide value to you
to me or our data team or anything like
that at high such and we're really happy
to use it here for these sorts of use
cases and there's
so many more use cases that make sense
in fact sometimes we triggers eight
years and i think i think
it's a different problem set what we
know is that integrating
core business data with a variety of
systems and kind of building a single
view of the customer is a specialized
problem that
isn't to be solved in like a
point-to-point wissy wake way
and it's to be solved properly on top of
a foundation like a data warehouse
but i think sometimes people have this
unilateral view of the world where
oh hydra just needs solution to this
it's the only way to do things in my
company that's just not
really true it's one of solutions in a
wider problem and we think
it'll tackle the majority of these cases
especially going in the long term but
but not necessarily all right got it
well um you mentioned um you know some
of the underlying architecture around
the current um way of ingesting stuff
into data warehouses
which makes perfect sense i wanted to
ask you you know switch gears a little
bit and talk to you a little bit about
the
design principles and um sort of the
architectural paradigms that you
followed
when building high touch because i know
there were some things
um in you reflected in the way that you
had built some things in segment that
you did differently in high touch um so
i wanted to ask you about that and
and see if you could share a little bit
more detail
totally i think there's a few things
here that are interesting
um so one thing is that
uh we we don't heavily use cues
for for data processing throughout our
infrastructure
and we process a lot of data in batch so
by processing a lot of data in batch
we don't need these individual messages
floating around and all these keys that
we're consuming and
we actually have more of the database as
a queue
uh within high touch which has has a
number of different advantages
there's definitely tradeoffs to vote
it's not it's there's not one globally
right answer
but i think it's super easy to
administer is one of the advantages so
by using your postgres database as a
queue
i our small team of engineers and devops
people can actually
can actually administer it um at ease
a lot of cues that are easy to
administer like nskew for example which
we which we later moved
out of to kafka at segment uh have have
a lot of issues when running
production systems where you can't lose
data i mean uh it's very easy to lose
data in the system because the the data
actually just gets deleted
once you acknowledge the message and
process it by the consumer that you're
writing
processing data from the queue whereas
cues
like kafka actually just have a layer of
persistence and the data is
persisted for a separate setting of how
long you say it should be persisted for
how much data you want to persist
and instead you're reading batches of
messages basically out of
a a persistent queue it's a very
different architecture but at the same
time
those services are actually super hard
to administer and integrate with
and add segment we had a whole team
dedicated to that so i think
using a database as a queue um and
just kind of as a queue of works to be
done to be read at it and uh have
batched the messages that we can read
out of systems like s3 has been like
a hack for us to um get by pretty far
and i think
might end up being our architecture
forever honestly um without having to
have
you know huge team like administering
this stuff and a bunch of uh
a bunch of complexities the other thing
which i think is actually more
interesting
is what we call our hybrid architecture
at segment
all right sorry at high touch not
segment uh so the way
most products in this kind of ecosystem
work is uh
data goes through a system and it gets
stored in its database
and uh all this sort of stuff to build a
single view of the customer before
syncing it out to other systems that's
how segment works that's how a lot of
systems work
around the uh around the ecosystem at
high touch we have this architecture
where basically
you can sign up self-service online and
then we use our own infrastructure but
you can actually
keep using hyatt as a sas service but
keep all the data
and state and storage of data inside of
your own infrastructure which is a
pretty interesting
uh architecture that helps us work with
like healthcare companies with
hipaa compliance fintech companies that
are just super stringent
um companies in europe that need data to
be persisted inside of their own region
et cetera at ease and how it works is
basically you can go into the high-tech
settings and actually provide
us an s3 bucket or a gcs bucket or an
azure bucket
um an awesome bucket etc and and
basically high touch will use that
instead of our own s3 bucket or our own
disk
to store all data so all the data is
queued up there
all the state of the last results we
sync to something like salesforce is
queued up there
when you look at our live debuggator app
and start poking through rows that fail
or anything like that or error messages
that might contain pii
all of that is stored in your
infrastructure we never save it on our
end
and that is pretty um instrumental for
us to work with like tons of other
companies and tons of large companies
like you know blend or
plaid or 3d madison without having to go
through
tons and tons of compliance and process
and things like that um
because we just don't store it storage
for data and our infrastructure uh and
then
i think uh the other thing that
the other principle that that we've had
at hyatt just we can do you can do
really complex things in terms of
setting up python with your
data infrastructure in our ui completely
self-service
um you actually can't even do some of
these things inside of tools that exist
like five strand
but one thing we've focused on is just
making it really
really easy to get set up even if you're
at a massive company that
has a bunch of infrastructure challenges
like if your data warehouse is in a
private network you need to create an
ssh tunnel or a versus stage channel to
uh connect high touch to that data
warehouse that's not publicly accessible
on the internet
you can do that all through the heights
ui and it'll generate ssh keys
tell you the command surrounding your
server give you a status check for it
it's all
completely self-service if you want to
give high-touch and s3 bucket
that um that you that you we use for
storing all the data that we need to
store to run our operations
you can do completely through our
settings pages and uis and that's pretty
powerful because a lot of times people
at large companies are like i want to
adopt this software
but i have to go through a bunch of
hurdles and because i need these
enterprise features i'm going to have to
talk to someone and ping my devops team
and all these things and
of course those things still happen i
mean every company is different there's
a lot of
layers of complexities in large
companies but because of this focus on
making everything self-service
we have fairly large companies that just
actually
set up high-touch end-to-end themselves
with a pretty complex security policy
and infrastructure and stuff like that
um just like they might set up things in
aws um
whereas i think if we didn't focus on
self's on making all these
complex product experiences self-service
uh
people might just default to writing
writing scriptures to not have to go
through the levels of
bureaucracy that most aspects require
you to do things like hybrid
architecture
well this is a really interesting
deployment model so
correct me if i'm wrong but are you
saying that um
you don't have a vpc you don't need to
have a vpc oriented
install for the customers because even
your own
sas cloud product has the option to sort
of store data
inside the client's infrastructure which
means that you don't actually have to
support a full vpc
which would have been the the previous
um you know sort of common wisdom in
in sort of enabling a sensitive or
secure
installation inside of a client's um you
know own
own private cloud exactly this
basically we're getting it's not fully
on-prem software right but we're getting
closer and closer to the benefits of
on-prem software
um without actually making you install
anything
by leveraging the fact that you have i
everyone has cloud providers that has
services that you can plug up to your
sas
which is which is actually kind of
incredible i think it's something that
we need to advertise a lot more and just
maybe talk about from a technology
perspective like basically all our
infrastructure and databases like you
know dynamodb
and postgres and like
whatever we have on our end all
basically source pointers to customer
data that lives
in the customer's own infrastructure as
for bucket rather than storing the data
itself
and that means haita doesn't even have
to implement things like
uh retention policies if you just turn
on an expiration policy inside of your
your amazon s3 bucket or whatever you
provide us
that data is just deleted and there's
there's no high-touch part of that that
can go wrong
which is a truly incredible guarantee
that helps us work with tons of
companies like i think
without this there's no way that um we
could have worked with companies like
you know
clad and blend within the first 10 years
of our operation
that actually integrate with like banks
and process things like
loans but it's just truly that this
architecture is fundamentally
a lot more secure and compliant uh than
than than your typical sas that
processes a lot of customer data
got it and would you say that this is a
competitive advantage um between you and
some of the other players in the space
yeah totally the fact that we basically
store nothing like no cash etc and use
an s3 bucket for this approach is is a
pretty large competitive advantage
um some of our competitors i
like like census for example i think
store
store the state of what was previously
synced back
into uh the customer's data warehouse
like into a redshift table or snowflake
tablet bigquery table
but then you can't really use those
tables to power features like a
row by row debugger inside of the ui
because you can't be querying the
customer's data warehouse to power those
sort of ui features
but what is fast enough to query an s3
bucket
that you have pointers to the specific
files you need to open at specific
offsets inside of your own database
so our architecture is pretty unique in
that in that manner where
we do power a lot of things up the
customer's data infrastructure but not
in a way that it bottlenecks their
development
because we just use the right cloud
services for the right tasks
um which i really think is pretty
exciting and i i think it's something
that's going to become more common
as just the whole ecosystem of
compliance grows
uh gross grows globally i think this
sort of hybrid architecture is going to
be something you see more and more of
that segment it's something we talked
about a lot but and maybe it'll happen
at some point too but just
logistically that's like a year plus
your bus project
for the number of products they have
that the number of databases they have
and queues they have and systems like
kafka they have and stuff like that it's
just
just crazy to implement a new
architecture like this at an existing
scale and i think
first hearing companies that have a lot
of regulation just like we see on-prem
software beating out
betters we might see like hybrid
architecture software uh you got
competitors in
the same way and not to say we wouldn't
do fully on-prem or something like that
down the road but the fact that that
we've been able to
um work with so many sensitive companies
with this architecture has been
tremendous because because on-prem
doesn't come without its own downsides
it's
very hard to do support and figure out
and debug and figure out what's going on
and on from
architecture where you have you know
thousands or hundreds of
companies running high touch inside of
their own infrastructure it's just
nightmare when people say something's
going wrong
definitely higher contract values to
justify it and and all sorts of things
so it's not to say we wouldn't do it but
definitely we want to invest in right
now yeah this hybrid approach is really
fascinating and i
i tend to agree with you i think you
should talk about this more
and um maybe we'll get you to give a a
data council talk on
on the topic because i think that would
be fascinating
josh would probably kill to do that
right
awesome yeah sure i think it's a lot of
fun too
when pitching engineers to join our
company it's actually a lot of fun to to
work with and it's not as
painful as on-prem either yeah that's
great
yeah that that sounds like a real
competitive advantage so um
very cool well um tejas it's great to
chat um i just wanted to ask you before
we let you go because i know you're a
busy guy with with lots of things to do
um what surprised you most about
working in the data ecosystem so far
yeah honestly i think what surprises me
most is
how fast things are moving despite how
old things are
a lot of people think oh these data
warehouses are blowing up and stuff
universes
have been around since i don't know the
70s the 80s like
as a concept and ibm's been playing in
space for
a really long time companies like like
uh
informatica are approaching or already
20 years old um data wrestling is an
age-old
problem but uh the velocity at which the
whole data because data ecosystem
started moving at the last 10 years with
you know
the rise of mobile the rise of just uh
analytics services etc and just
the data explosion inside of companies
has caused like
a huge wave of momentum over the last
um five years i think inside of uh
what's happening in the data space and
every week we wake up to new companies
and new ideas and
new open source projects and all these
new things that
affect how we think about our product at
high touch
what we want to pursue what we want to
integrate where we want to drive the
boundaries of our product and i think
the biggest thing that surprised me is
despite how all these things are how
quickly the ecosystem
has been moving yeah isn't that true um
it really has been explosion
uh especially even in the past few years
and um it's great to see
um high touch start to carve out this
category
on top of and to the right of the data
warehouse i think it's a really
interesting
space and generally in general in the
data ecosystem that
needs to fill out so um yeah kudos to
you and thanks for being on and sharing
some of your wisdom
and insight yeah totally glad to be here
um and to the rest of our listeners
thanks for joining
again uh we have another event in two
weeks
where christian zion from continual will
be here and he'll be talking about
machine learning on top of the data
warehouse so
it seems to be this person's a friend a
recurring theme yeah
tristan's awesome um and so we're
excited to have him on the show
um so don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and hit the bell icon to get
notified when we go online
again in the future thanks to just again
and thanks to all you for listening
we'll see you soon